-We're back with
Jennifer Hudson.
You know, every time
you've been on the show,
we have talked about
your accomplishments,
but you had a really big one
since last time you're here.
You were a producer
on a Broadway show.
-Yes.
-"A Strange Loop."
-Won a Tony.
That was your Tony
that completed an EGOT.
You've got all four --
Emmy, Grammy, Oscar, Tony.
-Yeah, that was surreal.
You know, I went
in support of the cast.
-Yeah.
-And when they said
"Strange Loop" won
for Best Musical,
I'm up there cheering
for the cast,
and everyone started chanting,
"EGOT, EGOT."
and I'm like, oh, whoa.
[ Laughter ]
I just won an EGOT.
-Yeah.
-They say that EGOT's
most likely to happen when you
don't know it's happened.
-[ Laughs ] I guess so.
-It's like a watched tea kettle
never whatever --
You know what I mean?
They say that about EGOTs.
So did you -- now you've got --
How do you display them?
-Well, I have an award wall
in my home in Chicago,
and the Oscar
sits in the middle.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
And it says, "Haaaa!"
And I said I would never
reveal the award wall
until the EGOT was complete.
But now that it is,
I think I need to,
like, redo the award wall,
and then I'll reveal it.
-I think you should have, like,
a mechanical sliding wall.
And when people come in,
they just see the Emmy,
and you're like,
yeah, I just won an Emmy.
And then you hit a button
and it's like,
oh, that's right,
I also have a Grammy.
Well, I'm sure
that's all of it.
[ Both imitating door opening ]
-I like that.
-Yeah. That's fun, right?
-You gon' wake up
and I'm gon' have it now, okay?
-I have good ideas about it
because I'm never going to
win the awards.
So you know what? I will give it
to you as a gift. Yeah.
-Okay. All right.
I will hold on to that.
-Do you have any dream guests?
Throw it out in the universe
for the next time you're here.
Who would you like to have on?
-Of course, Taylor Swift.
I would love to have her.
Um, Michael Jordan
is a dream of mine.
I know, I know
that's a tough dream.
And if I could pick Zendaya.
-Oh, that's a good three.
-Yeah, yeah.
-That's a good three.
Well, I wish that
you get all of that.
I feel like
with everything you have,
I can't imagine you're not
going to get that as well.
-Okay.
-And now you were talking
about your son, and how many --
how often does
he come and see your show?
-Not often, because
he's a basketball kid.
So he's heavily into sports.
-Okay.
How old is he now?
-He's 14.
-Oh, yeah. There you go.
-Yes. And now he's going
to school out in LA.
-Okay.
-So that's a new thing.
Before, I could drop him off at
school and then go to work.
-That's very exciting.
-Yes, it's very exciting.
-So you do need to have like
a basketball guest on the show
to have him show
any interest at all?
-I mean, then I'll be cool.
-Yeah?
It breaks my heart that
you're not cool to your son.
-You know? To your kids,
you're just Mom.
-Yeah. That's true.
-Yeah.
-No matter how many people --
like,
when I walk my kids to school,
every now and then,
people will be like,
"Hey, I love your show."
And they're like,
"Oh, what's that about?"
I'm like, "I have a show."
They're like, "When?"
-See?
-Yeah.
-Exactly. So you understand.
-Yeah. It's heartbreaking.
You know what my son said to me
the other day?
"When you die,
do I get your show?"
-David, don't you say that
to me. [ Laughs ]
Mine told me,
"Don't embarrass me."
-Oh, yeah. That's fair.
That's fair
not to be embarrassed.
Mine aren't old enough
to know what shame is yet.
-Well, you just wait.
-I know.
You know what we do
every year?
And we'll do it -- We're going
to film it this week.
So every Thanksgiving
since my son was --
I guess he was six months old
when we did our
Thanksgiving show.
We dressed him up as a turkey --
like as a baby in a turkey suit.
And then we've been
adding each year,
and now I got three kids
that we're dressing up
in a turkey suit.
And one of these days,
one of his friends at school
is going to be like,
"I saw you dressed
like a [bleep] turkey."
And he's going to come home
and be like,
"I did not consent to this."
-See?
-That day is going to come.
-That day is gonna come.
-Get ready.
-Yeah. Well, whatever.
Look, he should be happy.
When I die,
all of this is his.
[ Laughter ]
-That is true.
-Did you have any --
you know, like, when
I got this show, you know,
I obviously had in mind
the people who had it before,
you know, from Letterman
to Conan to Jimmy.
Like, what were
the daytime shows
that you were most impressed by?
-Well, of course, Oprah,
I loved -- I grew up
watching Oprah's show.
I love "The Ellen Show" as well.
And then I'm into like,
Tamron and Sherri
now as well, too.
-That's really cool.
It's really cool
to have those people
that were trailblazers that have
this path made for you.
It's really wonderful to watch.
-Yeah, I get
to learn from them all.
-There you go.
-And have my host voice.
-Yeah, you're very good.
Thank you for
making it back here.
And congratulations
on everything.
-Thank you for having me.
-You guys,
that's Jennifer Hudson.
"The Jennifer Hudson Show"
airs weekdays.
Check your local listings
and stick around
for Matt Rogers.